Now, what are we going to do now? For now, I
want to meet up with Keysut and the others. In
case we get separated, we have decided in advance where to meet up. It
seems like it's about a half-day ride from here by horse-drawn carriage. The witness from earlier said that horse-drawn carriages
come out regularly.  That's what I was saying,
but oh my, Shion, you're
probably already kissing me. It can't be helped.
That's just in case, of course, so I don't
want to be taken in easily by someone like that.  In the previous timeline, I
had a bitter memory, but I don't
have anything anymore. It's true. I lied. Just
fly over there and see. I
can hear the sound. You still have it. I still have it.  I'm not
going to go with the same theory as that, but I have
collected the effects of surrounding countries in advance so that anyone can escape smoothly.I wonder if I can
ride to the place with this?It's good to be
prepared.Maybe if I have that much, I can
ride to the place.  How much is the average price?
As expected, both of us are in the box. I wonder if I can
leave the negotiations to you? That's right.